hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast DNA standards and
bioinformatics benchmarks for meadow
genomics presented by dr. Christopher of
Nathan I'm Sydney Valdes of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this presentation is
interactive we want to hear from you
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not you will
not we will make sure to follow up with
you by email you can also enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon on the lower left
I'm sorry lower right hand corner of the
slide window if you cannot hear or see
this presentation properly let us know
by clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button in the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
this offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on a CD button located at the
bottom left hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process of obtaining your
credit I would now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. Christopher Mason
associate professor at Weill Cornell
Medicine Department of physiology and
biophysics dr. Manson's laboratory
builds and deploys biochemical and
computational technologies to understand
and engineer human and other genomes he
is a principal investigator Oracle
investigator on several NASA missions
and projects some missions will discern
the molecular basis of changes in the
human body during long-term human space
travel including genetic epigenetic
transcriptional and meta genomic changes
one additional mission is optimizing a
new method of space-based DNA nanopore
sequencing and his group is also
creating other genetic technologies and
algorithms that can measure nucleic
acids in space
notably the mana poor based sequencing
methods
he has pioneered with NASA and UCSF
scientists will enable mid-mission rapid
pathogen diagnostics for astronauts
create new applications of sequencing
for space exploration and discovered no
Nobel at DNA and RNA based modifications
I will now turn the presentation over to
dr. Mason great thanks so much for the
introduction that pleasure to be here
today I'm going to go through a number
of dissapoint to this video about what
is the current state of the art in
genetics and metagenomics in terms of
our standards that we're using to better
develop new tools as well as algorithms
to understand the world in US and also
the world around us so I'll start first
with the Philippines that live okay so
first is a little bit of history if you
think back of what used to be the case
for just simple things like threads on
screws and what was the distance between
them people literally couldn't build
things or even exchange different nails
and screws and fundamental bolts that
they would need to build things for
houses for businesses for anything as we
want to put together and so the
standards that were created over the
past 200 years make it fit that you can
go to any hardware store today and go
back to your house and build anything or
repair it or put it back together and
take it with it a bit so this is many
years coming but in sequencing space and
in genomics in general there was
historically a lot of work on lekker is
that created a lot of confusion about
whether it was the best microarray the
best way to in a high-speed quick
fashion
measure thousands or even these days
millions of loci simultaneously this was
true up until the early 2000s or like to
say the early noughties that is your
zero phase of the 2000s but what ended
up happening after the sequencer their
large proliferation of many kinds of
sequencers in 2000 5 6 and 7 is that
suddenly there was a similar problem as
a proliferation of methods for doing
sequencing but no real standards that
had yet been developed so one of the
calls to action from Nature
Biotechnology
2008 was to really try and develop
something like the MA QC or the micro
air quality control consortium to really
set these standards up so people could
really understand what they're looking
at and actually understand the
algorithms that could have their pros
and cons but the measurement of things
that you do sequence and this led to a
lot of international collaborative work
between industry academics and
government scientists we'll also the FDA
sequencing quality control consortium as
well to ABR a next-gen sequencing study
and I do a series of manuscripts in 2014
they really did a lot of deep
benchmarking in RNA sequencing and so
you can see here this was a lot of the
work we've done with many colleagues and
put out there on the existing platforms
but what's interesting well there's a
number of interesting things about the
study but one of my favorite things
about the study was when we'd sequence
even some samples of billions and
billions of reads we kept finding if
there was no real plateau as you can see
on the right we did see that the number
of reads map to different annotations
would depend to some degree on your
annotation itself and so the genome that
you will see in the transcriptome that
you will measure is to some degree and
even a large degree in some instances
dependent on your annotation but really
it means you keep sequencing deeper and
deeper and deeper this question of how
many rare isoforms and transcripts could
there be you know it means we kept
finding more and more isoforms more and
more genes present at very very low
levels and so we think that this means
there is no real complete base with
little sealing it seems like we get by
and partly due to cellular heterogeneity
and complexity and rare alleles present
but you can see here that we did keep
finding things and so what's interesting
is that today and you do metagenomics
research we can actually see that when
you take the same samples you can look
at here and you sequence up to hundreds
of millions of reads you keep detecting
new species they keep kind of popping up
using say another plant in this instance
to discover new organisms that are
present so what you do at 5 million 10
million or 30 million reads the problem
there is that you'll keep finding new
organs so this leads to a question of
well how many actually are there in my
sample how many total organisms can I
expect to find and this is a relatively
unknown of an answer in metagenomics or
even in microbiome research and so
so we've been working with a variety of
groups to look at this most notably one
of them is also again the NIST genes
anabolic consortium as well as the
sequencing quality control consortium
phase 2 which is the sexy to study from
the FDA most of the atf NGS phase 2
project which is looking at these
questions and we releasing all these
data online as they accuse eden finished
with the goal to have a lot of the
finish and that's actually a couple
months so one interesting thing is if
you take the human genome as a
perspective we could see here that you
know doing seven human genome stood with
deep characterization and posting on the
data online has led to a lot of people
being able to grab the data compare how
they're doing in their lab relative to
these are equal clear international
standards is also in concert with the
fda and precision fda so that as you
again generate a new protocol a new
method new sequencing basically protocol
in your lab you can immediately compare
how you're doing relative to these
international standards the other thing
that we've seen is you know there's no
standards for other kinds of areas for
example there's no standards yet for a
strange pink lake that exists you know
for example here you can see this Lake
Hillier from Australia and there's no
standard for a weird funky little pink
lake there's no standards yet for out
for example the Gowanus Canal which is a
Superfund site you can see here that
this is essentially a complete toxic
sludge site that we're taking samples
from but how do you standardize
extraction or methods from something
like this you know there just really is
no good standard so we want to have
standards apply to all these areas or
this there's no standard for a strange
collection of an organism that you might
find on a subway service or that people
are clearly afraid to touch and so there
are some standards that have been begun
but historically works like from the MD
QC the microbiome quality control
consortium did do some extraordinary
pioneering work in this direction but a
lot of it was initially focused on 16s
and so the NBA QC phase 2 is going to do
a little bit of both both 16s and
shotgun and look at extraction and
storage all that with complications and
caveats of different methods in
metagenomics microbiome research and so
so it's an exciting time because some of
these open questions are now beginning
to be addressed and so I'll discuss some
of them today
limitary daddy we've seen there's also a
number of other consortium groups the
microbiome standards or group which is
part of I am
there is also even a lot of work at the
NIH to make skin microbiome standards
which is relevant a very particular skin
research groups and all finally there is
a some work at NIST there is a workshop
just last fall and standards and
microbiome measurements which has led to
an international standards group called
EMSA the International metagenomics and
microbiome standards Alliance which
again is a collection of many people in
industry government and academia all
working together so one thing I want to
point out is when we think about what
you're measuring on a switch gears a
little bit to what's what's in the
organism and when you measure what it is
we can see here that the 16s RNA gene
for example which has been historically
broadly used for metagenomics research
is not actually even the best gene be
used if you had to use a team to
separate distantly related species and
most especially close through its
species you can see here in green
this is 74 different marker genes that
are present in most prokaryotes and 16s
rRNA is not even the best gene for
either these categories distantly or
closely related ones it's just one that
historically has had a lot of impact in
terms of discovering even the kingdoms
of life as well as for relative ease but
we all know that 16s is not perfect but
it has had some utility but you know
highlighting that point deeper is for
example the different lineages here you
can see at 16s versus at just general
interests identity a I can separate out
the lineages of ecoli for example or
Shigella different species where 16s
makes things to semi grand big us from
this paper published last year and so I
think it's fitting that you really never
before in biology and probably never
again will entire ecosystems and
kingdoms be viewed through the lens of
one gene I think rather we're reaching a
stage now where sharpened sequencing or
what is often called metagenomics can
now expand the microbiome measurements
to query across Kingdom so as you can
see here from this review paper
little bit of a formatting issue on the
bottom there but you can see Chuck and
let's you address a lot a lot more and
many different kinds of questions than
you put them to some of the targeted
I'll say is alone we do have a caveat
though is that if you're trying to avoid
human DNA you've course don't always do
that because you're just
taking shotgun samples for example your
skin you will get a lot more contaminant
DNA or host DNA they down the left I
think it's quite intriguing that you
really do see a lot of opportunities at
this date with shotgun sequencing we've
published some preliminary work on this
ensuring that actually you can look at
phages and infect the bacteria sort of
the top-ranking phages co-occur with
those strains and those species that are
most abundant so you actually have a way
to validate what's occurring in your
sample is being from shotgun city-based
microbe measurements but there are of
course challenges with love excitement
there's a lot of things you can measure
we really feel this is changing but
there are a lot of basically challenges
on all these methods of prep prep
extraction and maddux so in the prep
side and extraction we've published work
that shows the new multi enzyme cocktail
where they're using say a mega kit or
the mobile kit or doing a very seven all
different kinds of extraction for all
protocols we've seen so far that a multi
enzyme cocktail during the extracting
gives greater yield of nanograms from my
computer you can see here in red for
literally every kit that we've tested so
this is been ongoing work with the
medicine consortium to get better
methods for extracting especially for
low input samples and so this is one of
the things we've been focusing a lot on
we've also been looking a lot at what do
you think for was present in your sample
especially for things that are
potentially pathogenic and this is one
that was notably done in the New York
City Subway study where the potential
pathogens even when called by eight
different taxonomic Texoma classifiers
and then genetic algorithms are still
not enough in some cases distinguish
between closely related monophyletic
strains for example to some species of
bacillus and so we publish a strain
level analysis tool in this case with
one codex that could actually give you
an ability to distinguish in situation
Korea in 99.99% related species like an
cirrhosis in this case or other strains
of bacillus you could actually tease
denies looking at both the plasmids as
well as the specific snips which you can
would be impossible with 16s and so
using the data and really mining it
deeply as a way they give you strand
level specificity in a way that we have
never had before and also is which is
very important for public health as well
as provide defense this matters are key
not just in those contexts but another
ones as well so one in particular is
increase using meta genomics and we've
seen again with shotgun day you can
tease out what
present in this case we grew that were
cultured from environmental media before
and after antibiotic treatment with
tetracycline and we can see that which
gene was driving your systems for the
bacteria on the plate we could actually
pull out from the shotgun data look at
the ratio before and after treatment we
could see here for both genes on both
media coverage of tetracycline k1a much
faster and so this is relevant for work
at hospitals but also of course work in
even monitoring hospitals of the
patients themselves so that's more a
local context but we've also been
expanding this working to a more global
context and particularly one of my
favorite aspects actually of the subway
study would suspect that if you take all
the shotgun reason napkins in known
organisms really half the DNA ms unknown
known organism even with relatively
lenient blast criteria 90% identity
across 90% of the length this was a this
number that really represents the amount
of exciting unknown or mittens that
around us is you still have a good
genome assembly and we haven't yet
identified so this is actually not the
first time than we've been in the
situation when half the world honor us
as unknowns I would say is true of
course when Columbus Magellan set sail
this was the world that they thought it
was when they went out in the web of
course missing literally half of it and
I would argue that the same thing is
true when we had invented the microscope
something we could visualize this hidden
world duelist that was literally under
our fingertips and today sequencers
represent molecular microscopes that let
us because this world so one of the one
of the goals in the standards groups to
collaborate amongst many other groups
and this is a list of a lot of the sites
part of menace up and New York City's
really just one of the smaller cities
around the world so if you go to the
website you can actually see all the raw
data and all the work being done by hub
and collaborating cities around the
world to build up geospatial Maps of
meta genomics and antimicrobial
resistance markers and also we're using
these at a mine for New Boston a gene
clusters or new drugs so this is just a
nice visualization you can see if you go
to the website as well so far we've got
almost 6,000 samples taken worldwide and
more ongoing and is coming here this is
a part of an ongoing effort not just in
our group but also the other collaborate
left but a global effort really a Parsi
from the done one gig foundation is both
other groups to map antimicrobials
markers and see how they move in their
impact in different areas around the
world and also it's also part of the
nasa unlike the bio minute
so in the last part I mentioned for
Minnesota's work to using some of these
these tools and collecting device
ability even at large-scale human
migration events as we just completed a
collection at the Rio Olympics to see
what happens the city before during
after this large-scale human migration
event and we paired this every year on
June 21st with global ocean sampling day
group to monitor essentially what's
happening the medicine gimmicks of the
world dynamics at least once a year so
this again will be repeated again when
we get back to Rio so that's sort of
more normal and city-based name our
context as I lose those are extreme
contexts where we also really want to
use better benchmarking DNA standards
and tools and this is also make them
look at the extreme microbiome project
if you want to check out the website but
well the main reason we really want to
be here and that you're here today is to
think about you know in this universe
that we all share of ever increasing
entropy I like to say that the only
thing that can really save you is its
controls so particularly when I say
controls I don't just mean in silico
controls where you've computationally
mixed together species I would take that
to be sort of analogous to play those
forms or the Platonic forms where they
sort of represent the eternal forms of
what if you could perfectly mixed
together organisms which of course is to
some degree useful but it's the sort of
messy world of actual physically mixed
together or businesses and extractive
crafts and sequence where you get you
know I think a better view of the
insulated amounts of noise that can
happen in a laboratory so in particular
in the past year and a half we've put
together a variety of both simulated
biological data sets all of which are
available on the insa and it's your NCBI
website but these include samples which
some of which have been published
already from Nicholas tagada and other
great papers from other groups but then
also sequence samples of standards that
have just recently been developed we'll
talk about today and other datasets we
put together again at both simulated and
biological mixtures so too I want to
highlight most notably or one of the
ATCC controls this is one set of
controls of 20 species they've mixed
together they also have more controls
coming up very soon and also sine lines
of I omics controls you can see here as
these eight species of eight species
here both gram-positive and
gram-negative and they try to look at
what would be an unbiased extraction
versus other potential suppliers that we
know we're not getting perfect
extracting so this is on the extraction
side and these are the physical
that are available but I want to focus
most of the talk today about some
interesting things that we've seen on
the tools side on the algorithm side in
particular is an ongoing question about
people say well what should I use which
tool do I use it
here's one short list of all the
different kind of computational tools in
metagenomics you know it just cannot be
that everyone is the best what everyone
has their pros and cons as an ongoing
question on many forms and we've been in
the process of finalizing this papers in
review we just got the reviews back and
we're going to supporting it back in but
it's to really look at this question of
benchmarking a variety of different
algorithms you can see them all listed
here and to see how they do for a
variety of different standards datasets
so these are all very different
algorithms and we've actually quoted
them by all the resolution airs a little
bit low you can see here we've clustered
them by their so when they came out
what's their heuristic and their method
of function to map species how many
types of species and genomes and they
have across kingdoms of life that are
present in their current databases
through the new strain level and look
for an abaya kristance markers and some
of the factors about do they have say
for example tutorial or other parameters
for the run time so we've used these on
as I mentioned a good total of over 30
data sets that represent over 800
species titrated together and the
shorter the simplest one of the simplest
version was just the assignment
controller again you can see the eight
species of bacteria and also the two
fungi and we just want to detect you
know here's the theoretical composition
how did we actually do when we sequence
them so if you extract preference
sequence presentable
NextEra and kind seek effects we can
actually see here in this case keeping
with different cycles of PCR using one
codex to map the reads we can actually
see we really get some of our expected
friends and observed friends with a
little bit of a splash of human which
seems to go by a little bit more PCR but
what's interesting is we think you know
this sample is relatively simple had
these 10 species and you take things
that are more complicated other public
datasets so for example if you use the
ones that are known if we take some
other samples that we have that are
titrated public datasets that have say
53 species that we know are in this
sample what's interesting is if you say
how much be over that between say Megan
Clark or different tools you know
there's definitely a lot of wings to
this Venn diagram they do not always
agree as they should as you would like
and if you say give me only our top
species they actually disagree even a
little bit more and if you said you the
similar experiment if you say you only
have 22 species in this Illumina
sequence data set but you push the
algorithms to predict more than that you
consider very often will but the
disagreement gets much higher as you ask
them to predict more things that are
actually present in that sample there's
another example here which is 10 Jack so
again 3 steps in the middle and if you
push them many of the tools will predict
things at low abundance that are not
actually there the one piece of actually
interesting and I think good news is
that we put here on this axis the
percent agreement on average between the
tools and what is actually the number of
species in that sample and here it's
truth sit on the right so you can
actually see the mode of the
distribution of agreement between the
tools is where the likely actual number
of species in this sample is and so this
shows that even though tools will and
can and often do disagree where they do
tend to agree the most across at least
these 12 tools shows more likelihood
spot of the true number of species in a
sample which has been often hard to
discern and you can see here the summer
between the sort of last speak and true
size is actually quite good for what you
expect to see so that's on the
prediction side we've also then want to
see well what's the positive predictive
value of say pairs of tools coming
together essentially putting them
together not just tools but install
themselves but also combinations of
different tools and you can see when you
combine them they very often do much
better and this is also curious you do a
three tools sample you put together
three different tools really a positive
predictive value goes very much higher
and so but you do lose some sensitivity
which is often expected in this trade
off and it also one thing it's not
always better with three tools but it's
generally not worse I'd say here you can
see some of the data of combining tools
overall we've seen we're in the process
of also noting that really some samples
themselves are much harder than others
so not every sample is equally hard for
each other and you can see here are we
doing four different summaries of
different tools and which samples are
doing with more tools get wrong and more
kills get right you can see here this is
are essentially what we see with the
average positive predictive value for
these different tools and moreover if
you do a rock clawed or receive Robert
your characteristic plot you can see
those other trails for different tools
and these are you know the not final
versions of these plots for
some updated code for new samples but
you can see here there are some
trade-offs there as well so that's one
detection side that's one problem but
we've also found that abundance can also
be quite difficult and so if you look
here how well the different tools
predict the actual abundance of species
not just a present you can see we get a
wide range of variation for some
algorithms where those can maintain a
very tight distribution around the
expected abundance for different
organisms and this you can see here is
when you'll get a wide range of variants
for different tools but some samples are
harder than others and some tools do
better than others and we can see that
this is another factor as well so this
is again and I'm going work not just at
this beat at the broad level where you
get from a sample but also read by read
analysis is also something we've been
looking at this work with our sheet on
it is to see what Cadell games do at the
if you only have five reads how well do
you do not fit across all the markers of
all the reads here we've actually seen
that Clark does particularly well as
well as one codex is quite well the
blast is also pretty good here but you
can see that you can get a wide range of
specificity and sensitivity for
different tools at the sort of read by
read measurement and you can see here
how some the tools are performing again
they're in review now and the final
results will be posted online actually
very shortly so that's at the
measurement and the abundance and the
detecting side but there are other
ongoing questions that of course arrives
from metagenomics research so what about
DNA modification there RNA as well here
we're going to see the epigenetics when
you look at on PacBio sequencing you can
actually predict modified bases from the
kinetic information from the back bio
data itself and here when we've taken
design lestranges other pooled samples
we can see that the pooled sample has a
different signature than with individual
strains for their potential base
modifications that are present and so
far we can actually see this class 1
standard does have some really
interesting motifs most of them for
nickel 6 adenosine from about the for
cytosine which are expected from some of
these samples but it's always good to
remember not just the genetic standards
but also these sequencing
sequencing these controls on single
molecules sequence much like backed by
our Oxford nanopore will give you an
ability to look at the epigenetic states
as well of these controls and eventually
there will be a bit more examples of
direct
RNA sequencing in this paper this was
the first example of using the same idea
of a kinetic information for deliberate
incorporating bases to monitor the
modified status of the template strand
but in this case we worked with PacBio
and you know spore life and others to
put together a reverse transcriptase at
the bottom of the zmw look at the
kinetic information essentially watching
see DNA synthesis occur in real time for
a regular adenosine versus modified
adenosine and look at the change in the
incorporation speed so this was the
first time that we showed that you can
actually detect modified RNAs directly
there was your CDA synthesis and this is
relevant of course because we've seen in
the last year that both HIV as well as a
lot of other viruses are methylated the
RNA itself contains methylation of
methyl six identity of its present and
it's not just for HIV it's also dengue
yellow fever Zika and West Nile virus
we literally every single RNA virus
we've looked at today has slight
variation that these Peaks in red we see
focus spots of RNA methylation the
significance of which these likely
controlling the nuclear export and
localization and also their function
during infections so to an exciting time
for microbiome metagenomic smells on the
RNA side the meta transcriptomics or is
the RNA virus like to say it's just
their genome X of course so the final
piece I want to bring up with importance
of standards and where else are these
standards taking us so is the
interplanetary context it's really sort
of low Earth orbit context but quite
seriously we are on working with NASA on
several missions one of the NASA twin
study which starts to look at the
genetic aspects of spaceflight and also
to improve Diagnostics during
spaceflight on the space station so in
particular this is the work with the
twin city we're looking at as you can
see here a circle spot of all the multi
Olmec data so this is genome microbiome
epigenome transcriptome at the
transcriptome metabolomics as well as
basket your cognition in a real
integrated tamiya logical profile of
astronauts six months before flight one
year in space in six months upon
returning this is Martin Scott Kelly who
generously donated literally blood sweat
and tears to the study so this is an
ongoing work with NASA to improve this
and so again when we're sequencing
someone far away and the space station
we want to make sure we get it right
using some of the aforementioned
controls but more excitingly we also
have also you know
able to think about not just bringing
all the samples back but could we
actually do sequencing in space rather
than you know have some the hassle of
things burning up in the atmosphere
sometimes or taking a while to get back
to you so this is an ongoing project led
by Aaron Burton at NASA is called the
biomolecule sequencer we're working with
them to actually do Diagnostics in space
so this is so as always with a mission
you need to pack so you can see here is
the mission patch at the biomolecule
sequencer project you can see you're the
Nano for let's take a little rocket
going into space and as we're actually
playing this mission we were working in
childs chatting with auntie Feinberg one
of the NASA twins guys we're talking
about certain sn1 needs up and as that
happening actually supplies going up to
the space station and the Sierra 7
actually blew up on the way there which
was very sad because it's never good
when your lab supplies explode but my
favorite thing about this explosion was
a really touching letter I'd gotten from
NASA that said really encouraged us to
hang in there and keep going even though
they do love our stuff on accident so
we're really going to maintain the
course and keep fighting for the science
it was really touching letter I'll note
that when you get a cut from the NIH for
your budget you Jenna kind of seeing
email I think this is a little bit more
personal I encourage the NIH to do the
same so and also space is hardest stuff
that Kelly tweeted so we did have an
opportunity though as we're planning the
mission the and ever waiting for
resupply rocket we thought well let's
actually try it on the parabolic flight
simulator because in this case you get a
little bit of zero gravity but only for
about 12 to 15 seconds but let's see if
it'll you know maybe it'll work there so
in this gives Andy Feinberg who actually
got up there and did manage the load a
flow cell in zero gravity with these
positive displacement pipettes gotten up
there working lowered the flow cell and
we actually showed about a year and a
half ago that it was possible to
sequencing zero gravity and the
interesting thing is we observe some
slight fluctuations in current that we
now see are this part of normal flow
cell variation but at the time we were
very intrigued with this concept that
the flight current does looks like it
was different from the ground at the
exact same live we got on earth 12 in
zero gravity seemed to be shifted and
again this is no more to normal flow
cell variability in terms of the people
and current of essentially what's going
through the pore per Kaymer
ordered by hmm
which is now an RNN Bacharach's you see
here that this gives you sort of a wave
form this kind of inspire us to think
about now well what other place where we
see wave forms and can we use them to
match to basically different databases
one particularly one is in Shazam of
course and so a lot of conversations
that would hopefully about this idea
involve well let's actually see if we
could create an algorithm that would do
this and match the known wave forms
which we call downfall the unopen source
song of genomes algorithm section
massive fingerprints of genomes and
that's you can see here and this work
was recently published in the journal
Nature partnered in electro gravity so
you can see here that in zero-g two
current versus 1.8 G and then zero-g
1.80 as you go up and down the flight
simulator you can see the impact of
gravity on a metaphor is actually not
that bad at all so it's good to see that
the four works great and zero or a
higher gravity as well and then it'll
work when you get to the space station
was what we thought would happen
so as we're continuing to plan the
mission this is actually Kate Rubin's is
getting ready to go up to space and do
it loading her first low so doing
planning missions at Houston she
eventually got up to the space station
milk problem and actually when they send
more resupplies up there and this year s
nine you can see are the perfect refers
to return landed back down earth and as
of last august we can see that we could
sequence in space with a relative ease
actually and that cave Rubens was the
first person to sequence DNA off this
planet to going up to about a billion
sequence reads and this work is now in
with you as well but one notable piece
of the data was actually we could see if
you look down here that the percent
identity for one name to be reads and
this is older chemistry that version
seven flow cells this was pretty good
and actually was actually slightly
better for the flight data than the
ground a so it seems like the
zero-gravity sequencing really had gave
no problems at all for the device and
for that for the technology work well so
we're going to take all these reads and
put them together to do a de novo
assembly of e.coli and as you can see
here compared to the gold standard
packed by our genome assembly that we
did the same sample here at Cornell we
can see really get almost perfect you
don't assembly when compared to pack bio
and really we can demonstrate that this
is the first genome sequence and
assembles the data not made on this
planet so it was still orbiting the plan
mind you but and not from this one so
it was a pretty exciting set of data to
get over the past six months and put
together and I can tell you also we've
been getting additional data from the
space station doing addition of
replicate runs and the data it looks
very very good actually means that the
flow cells laughs likely long enough to
get to Mars we wanted to send something
to Mars to try and get a diagnostic
there it looks like they would make it
so it's pretty exciting and also we are
sending up these imal controls the tiger
mixer will be a truly you know control
use for all contacts including space and
just as flying up there in the next
resupply mission and we'll get that data
back down there as bearson so this is
essentially what the new poster actually
for NASA is they call it the sort of
space genomics poster actually have one
of those here in my office right now you
can see right there that they just sent
me today so this is the idea that we
really can use sort of integrated
molecular diet diagnostics and profiling
and personal omics profiling to really
look at all the dynamics of the human
genome human microbiome and either the
total sort of biome that is the space
station enter the humans on their way
towards other plants you can see here
floating toward tomorrow so it's pretty
exciting time for molecular diagnostics
both here on other world as well so I'd
also point out that you know I think
it's not just thinking about how do you
measure things but eventually I think
the real test of understandably how you
also grow things and so this part of the
bio Academy class that we're also
working with some people mature to have
on this and others and also want to
thank finally people from the Brooklyn
bioreactor which is given us some of the
most challenging mysterious and peculiar
samples to look out for some of the
standards development and computational
methods testing and on 60 years the
pioneers to do continue a microbiome
monitoring with the Brooklyn bioreactor
and along the way we will be using the
standards both physical and
computational and really the next steps
I'd say is that you know more kingdoms
is harder but I think it's better I
think more data is more happiness we use
this positive control for all the
medicines like collections have been
using it in the clinical lab as well
really is our to positive control these
both design MO and the ATTC as well as
the ABR FNG @rg control so we use them
all and this I think points to the fact
that we need really a constant gardening
effort really as a community for both
the tool standards and the benchmarking
to make sure we all improve things
gather and use the standards that data
is comparable between sites and of
course that's not really new you should
always have positive and negative
controls so at the end I want to thank
everyone in the laboratory who really
helped with this project and really as
wouldn't be possible without them so
deep gratitude to the funders including
the wolf bun foundation NIH to Bailey as
well as the NHGRI and also the Virgin
Foundation also gates and NASA limestone
foundation thank you very much for your
time and have a great day
happy taking questions thank you for
that wonderful presentation dr. Mason we
want to get right to the questions and
input so here's a reminder as to how
audience members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via Q&A
button at that lower left if we are
unable to get to your questions due to
time constraints dr. Mason will be
answering them submitted questions via
email so let's look at our first
question
dr. Mason what algorithms are best for
bacteria or viruses great question so
different race models have different
different tools at different data bases
as we pointed out one of the earlier
slides and that's really one of the
biggest factors in what you'll detect is
what in the database of the tool that
you use so we've seen though that really
you know most of the tools that have
bigger bacterial databases do a really
good job so this includes one codex
cosmos IV blast against everything meta
fine does a pretty good job it's
recently expanded its databases and I so
Clark has a very large database oh those
are some of our all those tools are some
of our go to tools that we do routinely
and so that goes into like recommend but
the biggest Factory is the side of the
database both for viruses and bacteria
thank you we also have another question
from an audience member who wants to
know our DNA Standards Committee
purchased today yeah good question a
good question so we they're actually
publicly available the standards for
from both Deimos wells ATTC and the mdrd
are also synthesized by a TCC so all the
standards I've mentioned the physical
standards the ones you can use they
allow are available as pure DNA as well
as pure life lies that cell extract so
you can get them use them test them and
really different going on your left we
want to make sure the standards are
usable long term and for many
experiments so it won't end up online if
you have any questions you can't find it
like Google just send me an email
thank you dr. Mason again for your
wonderful presentation do have any final
comments that you'd like to make for the
audience before we end I guess I just
say I'm going to stay curious and know
that we've really just started
discovering all the world that's already
around us so I think it's it'll be a
very fun period in science the next five
to ten years that we can really sell
they see this invisible world so but
that I encourage everyone you know while
taking up with that excitement too don't
forget to always have like you do on
every plate in lab a positive and a
negative control and make sure you've
got some sanity checks and then you can
actually have a lot more faith in
interpreting your data and and discover
more
wonderful thanks again dr. Mason I'd
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for up to six months
keep an eye out for an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we
encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's event thanks for
joining us today and we hope to see you
next time goodbye